تتجدد يوميات الحرب الاوكرانيه موشيكا على
اتمام عام بعد اقل من 24 ساعه من قصف روسي
مكثف استهدف منشات اوكرانيه للطاقه اعلنت
كييف الجمعه انها صدت هجوما بمسيرات
متفجره شانه الجانب الروسي كانت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت استهداف مواقع
للقياده الاوكرانيه ومنشات الطاقه تغذي
الصناعه عسكريه
وبحريه مكثفه على مواقع القياده الاخرانيه
انشاءات الطاقه المعنيه بتشغيل مؤسسات
المجتمع الصناعي العسكري الاوكراني ودمرت
جميع الاهداف
احسن ناطق العسكري الروسي مئات القتل
الاوكرانيين وعشرات المواقع والاليات
المدمره يتطاير شضل الحرب وراء الحدود
وتتواصل تداعيات سقوط الصاروخ الاوكراني
في بيلاروسيا ولا يستبعد قائد قوات
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات في وزاره
الدفاع البلاسيا ان يكون الحادث استفزازا
الاوكرانيا دون ان ينفي اطلاقه بشكل غير
مقصود
من جانبه ابدى قلقا شديدا وقال الناطق
باسمه ديمتري بيسكوف ان قوات روسيا وبيلا
روسيا على اتصال وتنسيق دائمين بما يتيح
امكانيه التبادل السريع للمعلومات الاكثر
حساسيه واضاف بيسك اوف ان بيلاروسيا اتخذت
عدد من الاجراءات بهذا الشان اتجاه الجانب
الاوكراني المواقف الاكرانيه وبعيدا عن
خبر الصاروخ تواصل التاكيد في ظل توافق
يصفونه بالكامل مع واشنطن على عدم تقديم
اي تنازلات بشان استقلال اراضي اوكرانيا
وحدتها وسيادتها الكامله على كل شبر بما
في ذلك شبه جزيره القرم هي مجوز كزاد
لدينا توافق مع الجانب الامريكي في جميع
القضايا بنسبه 100% هم يتفهمون ما هي
نهايه الحرب وما هي الاهداف والتنازلات
التي لا يمكن تقديمها الجانب الامريكي
يداعم لنا ويؤمن بان انتصارنا هو انتصار
له ايضا
سياسي يضمن سياده اوكرانيا جاء ايضا في
تصريحات لامين عام حلف الناتو
الذي اعتبر ان دعم كلاب عسكريا هو الطريق
الاسرع لتحقيق السلام مضيفا ان الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على اهداف عسكريه في روسيا
مشروعه تماما تصريحات تاتي بعد ساعات من
اعلان روسيا عن التصدي مجددا لما وصفت
باهداف مجهوله فوق قاعده انجلز الجويه في
العمق الروسي والتي تستهدف وفق الجانب
الروسي للمره الثانيه خلال الثلاثه ايام
ويبقى ان التاييد الاطلسي لهجمات
الاوكرانيه عابره للحدود ياتي رغم التاكيد
الامريكي على عدم تحديد ذلك حذرا من تصعيد
يفضي لمواجهه امريكيه روسيه مباشره